l'ordre du jour appelle le débat veolia
suez quel rôle doit jouer l'état
stratège pour protéger notre patrimoine
industriel demande du groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains
la parole est tout d'abord aux orateurs
du groupe qui ont demandé ce débat
monsieur patrick kanner président du
groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le débat
qui nous réunit aujourd'hui a pour
vocation d'éclairer le rôle que doit
jouer l'état dans la définition de notre
politique industrielle
cette question centrale en temps normal
devient essentiel en temps de crise car
depuis un an l'épidémie de covin 19 agit
comme un révélateur des failles de notre
société
les fragilités de notre modèle
industriel sont apparus en pleine
lumière
quand il a fallu faire face à des
pénuries de produits de matériel qui
pouvait seul à l'époque nous permettre
de lutter contre la maladie
les preuves que nous traversons a
néanmoins d'intérêt elle remet enfin au
centre du débat public la question de la
reconquête industrielle
c'est donc notre conception de la
souveraineté nationale dans ce domaine
qui est interrogé pour illustrer ces
thèmes il est apparu au groupe
socialiste écologiste a vu qu'un que
j'ai l'honneur de présider que ce qu'on
peut bien légitimement qualifier
d'affaires veolia suez était une clé
d'entrée pertinente
le 30 août dernier veolia numéro un
français de la gestion de l'eau et des
déchets annonce son intention de
racheter le numéro 2 son concurrent
historique suez en se portant candidat à
l'acquisition des parcs angie avait
annoncé céder depuis nous suivons les
différents aléas d'une au pea qui
n'avait d'amical manifestement que le
nom et qui a fini par assumer
franchement son caractère hostile soit
on pourrait y voir le déroulement normal
d'une opération économique entre deux
grands groupes industriels
on pourrait accepter l'état de fait
dire que c'est une situation classique
dans une économie de marché mondialisée
mais peut-être dans sa pire acception
c'est à dire une économie mondialisée
mais non régulés or nous ne sommes pas
prêts à accepter ce qui se déroule
depuis plusieurs mois pour deux raisons
la première concerne le rôle de l'état
la seconde touche aux conséquences qui
pourraient découler de cette affaire
depuis le départ je vous le dis
franchement monsieur le ministre la
position de l'état n'est pas clair la
rapidité de l'offensive fait par d'eolia
interroge vous me répondrez que vous
avez eue vrai pour qu'un délai
supplémentaire soit accordé pour que
suez puis soumettre une offre
alternative certes mais objectivement un
délai de cinq jours c'était bien court
vous me direz également que le
représentant de l'état se sont opposés à
la cession des parts d'énergie à veolia
mais leur vote finalement on n'a été que
symbolique tant les autres parties en
présence qui aurait pu rejoindre la
position de l'état ont fait basculer
très opportunément le vote final en
s'abstenant ou en quittant la salle
pouvons-nous pouvez vous accepter un tel
camouflet
aujourd'hui veolia détient 29,9 pour
cent des parts de suez encore récemment
la proposition des dirigeants de suez en
date du 21 mars a été rejetée par veolia
et la voix de l'état n'a pas été entendu
alors que cela aurait pu aboutir au
rapprochement amical que vous appelez de
vos voeux
pour toutes ces raisons et bien d'autres
que mes collègues sénateurs et
sénatrices porteront l'action de l'état
nous interrogent elles me semblent bien
timide et n'a pas pour l'heure eu de
résultats si vous ne représentait qu'un
actionnaire privé monsieur le ministre
les marchés vous auriez sanctionnés
constatant la faible qualité de votre
action et le manque de rentabilité du
travail donné mais vous n'êtes pas un
actionnaire comme les autres vous
représenter l'intérêt général or les
conséquences pour l'intérêt général sont
bien réels vous les connaissez
car vous même le 29 septembre 2020 dans
une interview vous avez défini à juste
titre les quatre conditions préalables à
tout rachat
je voulais rappelle genoux les rappels
protection de l'emploi protection de
l'empreinte industriels une offre à
majorité française et une offre amicale
à ce stade
nous constatons que ces conditions ne
sont pas remplies à ce stade vous n'avez
pas été en mesure de nous apporter des
garanties que ce soit envers la
représentation nationale mais également
et c'est peut-être plus grave envers les
salariés concernés
comment pouvons-nous garantir que cet
opéra n'entraîne pas des conséquences
sociales environnementales et
territoriales qui impacterait
durablement notre pays
comment pouvez-vous nous garantir
monsieur le ministre que les
collectivités locales qui sont
extrêmement sensibles
cette affaire entre guillemets veolia
suez verront leur intérêt préservé au
travers de leurs intérêts l'intérêt des
concitoyens de ces collectivités locales
comment pouvez-vous nous garantir que la
compétitivité d'un nouveau groupe d'une
telle taille ne soit pas fortement
menacée comment pouvez-vous nous
garantir que cela ne favorisera pas
l'apparition d'acteur entre guillemets
low cost moins disant social mme en
conclusion monsieur le ministre nous
voulons aujourd'hui vous entendre sur
des choix politiques qui découle d'un
laisser-faire selon nous dommageable
les choix qui n'incarnerait plus
l'intérêt général déchoir que qui
remettent en cause finalement une
véritable politique industrielle
en tout cas nous pensons que cette
politique industrielle aujourd'hui doit
être réinventé notamment au regard de la
crise je ministre en cette période si
particulière
le choix n'est pas entre moins d'état et
mieux d'état mais à la reconstruction
d'un état stratège en matière
industrielle
merci pour les réponses que vous avez
bien nous apporter dans quelques
instants
merci chers collègues la parole et à
hervé gillé pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains pour 3
minutes
[Applaudissements]
ce président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues loupé à se voulait
amical mais les hostilités ne cesse dans
un contexte pandémique provoquant des
incertitudes financières
etait-il vraiment opportun pour le
groupe angie de vendre ses
participations dans suez le gouvernement
a semble-t-il désapprouvé dans un
premier temps alors que la caisse de
dépôt et de consignation a salué par la
voix de son directeur général cette opa
amicale rompant avec sa neutralité
classique
faut-il le rappeler la cdc pèse 10% des
droits de vote au sein de veolia mais
néanmoins son conseil de surveillance
n'a pas donné son avis sur cette
opération
toujours est il que les 18 euros d'offre
d'achat initial sont désormais le niveau
des actions de suez ce qui laisse rêveur
sur les dernières spéculations
du fait de l'ampleur de cette opé à la
commission européenne à la concurrence
est désormais saisie en relation etc
trop notre haute autorité car il s'agit
bien d'interroger les effets collatéraux
notamment sur le marché français
collectivités locales et territoriales
syndicats
régis sont désormais dans une
incertitude sur les évolutions et les
évolutions du marché
la séquence interroge de nombreux
décideurs elle crée sans aucun doute un
appel d'air sans précédent pour les
concurrents intermédiaire soucieux de
peser davantage et dans la tente de
cessions d'actifs imposées par les
autorités
difficile de percevoir le véritable
projet industriel de veolia nous on dit
ion dans le cadre d'un comité de suivi
nos auditions dans le cas d'un comité de
suivi n'ont pas permis en l'état de
mettre en évidence un risque
concurrentiel des opérateurs chinois
encore moins sur le marché français qu'à
l'international al'inverse la séquence
va renforcer la financiarisation des
deux opérateurs alors qu'il faudrait un
an cage actionnariale avec une vision à
long terme le risque de fonds activiste
est purement spéculatif est réel et
inquiétant
angie aurait pu développer des
coopérations industrielles marques ayant
des compétences énergétique et
environnementale en travaillant sur la
numérisation des données dans une
approche de smart cities très attendu
le groupe a préféré vendre stratégie
peut-être plus politique qu'industriel
quelles seront les incidences sur
l'ensemble des usagers sur les
collectivités locales et territoriales
et les syndicats prenons un exemple avec
les concentrations actuelles en
remportant la délégation du service
public pour la gestion de l'ensemble des
incinérateurs de la métropole bordelaise
veolia implicitement créer un
différentiel de prix conséquents entre
la métropole et le reste du département
dans un marché captif du fait de
l'absence de concurrence à l'heure des
coopérations territoriales
voici un exemple provoquant suez
aujourd'hui multiplie les projets de
cession veolia y voient une volonté
d'amplifier les dividendes pour
consolider sa majorité et sa gouvernance
dans la tempête actuelle ni les usagers
ni les collectivités ni les salariés en
seront les gagnants
il faut siffler la mi-temps mais comment
finir le match
monsieur le ministre le voulez vous en
avez vous les moyens
je vous remercie bien merci chers
collègues la parole est désormais à
monsieur bruno le maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la relance
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
la position de l'état sur le sujet de
veolia de suez a été constante
nous souhaitons que cette opération se
fasse dans un cadre amiable
nous refusons que le conflit l'emportent
sur le dialogue et nous refusons la
guerre de tous contre tous qui ne fera
que des perdants
l'état avait fixé des conditions pour
répondre à la question de patrick kanner
pour décider de soutenir ou non la
cession par angie de sa participation
dans suez et veolia puisque l'état est
actionnaire tenshi mais je le rappelle
actionnaires minoritaires la pérennité
de l'emploi qui est évidemment un sujet
majeur
la logique industrielle la préservation
d'une autre concurrentiel qui est
essentiel pour les collectivités locales
auquel vous êtes évidemment
particulièrement attachés et enfin
l'intérêt patrimonial l'état étant
actionnaire de veolia avait pris un
certain nombre d'engagements sur ces
points notamment sur l'emploi sur
l'investissement sur le maintien de la
recherche et du développement en france
mais j'ai toujours été très clair je le
rappelle sur le fait que cette opération
devait être amical c'est à dire accepter
par le conseil d'administration de suez
et par l'ensemble est partie prenante
dans cette affaire j'ai pris mes sur le
sénateur mes responsabilités dès lors
que cette offre n'était pas acceptée par
le conseil d'administration de suez
j'ai demandé que le représentant de
l'état au conseil d'administration d'
angie vote contre la cession des
participations d'énergie dans swayze
n'avons pas été suivis par le reste du
conseil j'ai dit que je le regrettais
mais je rappelle que nous ne sommes pas
majoritaires dans ce conseil
d'administration ça d'ailleurs pose un
certain nombre de questions sur la
participation de l'état dans certaines
entreprises et sur le fait que
finalement elle se retrouve juge et
partie je suis heureux d'entendre dire
que dans certains cas effectivement je
considère que l'état ferait mieux de
défendre
l'intérêt général en dehors des
entreprises plutôt que l'intérêt général
dans les entreprises sauf pour des
services publics où certaines
entreprises stratégiques c'est ma
position constante depuis quatre ans que
je suis ministre de l'économie et des
finances et cette affaire n'a fait que
me conforter dans cette conviction que
l'état a sa place dans des grands
services publics dans quelques
entreprises stratégiques mais pour le
reste il se retrouve très vite juges et
parties c'est-à-dire à la fois décevant
défendre son intérêt patrimonial et puis
dans le même temps devant défendre
l'intérêt général il se retrouve
déchirée entre deux obligations qui sont
contradictoires la meilleure façon de
trancher ce noeud qui est un de gordien
c'est d'accepter que l'état se retire
ses participations d'entreprises qui ne
sont pas stratégiques
cela n'empêche pas bien au contraire
l'état de jouer un rôle important dans
notre économie et dans l'industrie
est ce que cette crise économique a
montré c'est que nous avions besoin d'un
état fort et responsable dans le domaine
économique pour fixer des orientations
garantir d'attractivité notre territoire
faciliter le financement de l'innovation
de la recherche qui fera la puissance de
la nation française et de l'europe au
21e siècle
et de ce point de vue là je tire quatre
leçons de cette crise actuelle dans la
définition de la place de l'état dans
l'économie
la première c'est que la première
responsabilité de l'état
c'est tout simplement de faire en sorte
que la nation soit attractive pour les
investisseurs étrangers dont dépendent
beaucoup d'emplois toutes les décisions
que nous avons prises sur la baisse de
l'impôt sur les sociétés sur la baisse
de l'impôt de production qui est
indispensable pour être activités
industrielles du pays
tous ces choix que nous avons fait avec
le président de la république depuis
2010 cette news en tout simplement
permis de devenir la nation la plus
attractive pour les investissements
étrangers en europe
c'est un bon résultat c'est la
responsabilité de l'état et c'est à lui
et à lui seul qu'incombe la
responsabilité de rendre la nation
française attractive c'est sa première
responsabilité sa deuxième fonction
vitale
au lendemain de cette crise où les
innovations technologiques
s'accélérer c'est de financer les
investissements dans l'innovation c'est
de faire le choix des innovations de
rupture c'est de soutenir sans cesse
l'investissement l'investissement est
toujours plus d'investissements de ce
point de vue là le maintien du crédit
d'impôt recherche le soutien à la
recherche fondamentale
l'identification des chaînes de valeur
que nous avons fait
évidemment nous ne sommes plus dans les
années 60 donc cette identification des
chaînes de valeur elle n'est pas venue
d'en haut
elle est venue des chercheurs et des
revenus des industriels elle est venue
des économistes elle est venue de ceux
qui sont au plus près du terrain et des
attentes des consommateurs nous ont
permis de définir un certain nombre de
nouvelles chaînes de valeurs sans
lesquelles la france va investir
l'hydrogène le calcul quantique les
biotechnologies l'agroalimentaire les
batteries électriques pour qu'on garde
toute la valeur de la production de
véhicules électriques en france plutôt
que de laisser partir à l'étranger en
asie ou ailleurs c'est pour moi la
deuxième fonction essentielle encourager
l'innovation soutenir l'investissement
la troisième c'est de défendre un modèle
social auquel nous sommes attachés et
singularité française qui s'appelle les
services publics les services publics
sont une fierté française avoir un grand
service public ferroviaire c'est une
fierté française avoir un grand service
public de l'électricité avec edf
c'est une fierté française et arrêtons
de considérer que ces services publics
pourrait être un poids dans notre nation
je considère au contraire qu'ils sont un
atout un facteur d'attractivité et un
garant d'efficacité en la matière de ce
point de vue là cela justifie que nous
ayons déployé plus de 4 5 milliards
d'euros dans le plan de relance pour la
sncf et je pense que c'est un bon
investissement et cela justifie que nous
négocions pied à pied avec la commission
européenne
une réforme d'edf qui maintiennent
l'unité de cette grande entreprise
énergéticienne quête edf
je veux le dire à cette tribune avec
beaucoup de force
nous refuserons tout démantèlement d'edf
nous voulons transformer edf pour
qu'elles investissent davantage
notamment dans les énergies
renouvelables et cela peut se faire en
maintenant l'unité du groupe
c'est en tout cas avec le président de
la république notre ambition enfin la
quatrième responsabilité de l'état c'est
évidemment de protéger protéger de
technologie protégée de savoir-faire
protéger notre indépendance à ne soyons
pas naïfs sur le monde dans lequel nous
entrons les investissements sont parfois
des investissements de pillage et pas
des investissements de développement les
investissements de développement sont
les bienvenus en france les
investissements qui créent des emplois
sur notre territoire sont les bienvenus
en france les investissements qui
permettent de développer nos entreprises
d'accroître l'activité sur les
territoires sont les bienvenus en france
mais les investissements de court terme
qui consiste uniquement à s'intéresser à
une technologie dans une pme dans une
télé française pour s'approprier ce
savoir faire à cette technologie est
ensuite se retirer au bout de quelques
mois ou de quelques années ces
investissements ne sont pas les
bienvenus ce sont des investissements de
pillage et nous les refusons nous avons
à 275 reprises en 2020 utiliser le
décret aux investissements étrangers en
france précisément pour stopper ces
investissements de pillage et protégé de
technologie je me réjouis que l'union
européenne à son tour et pris conscience
de cette nécessité et avancer dans cette
voie là voilà mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
l'idée que nous nous faisons de l'état
dans l'économie il a un rôle essentiel à
jouer mais il doit être clairement
définis
créer un environnement favorable à
l'investissement encourager l'innovation
préserver nos services publics protégés
de technologies de pointe
voilà ce à quoi je m'attache au plus
près de quatre ans
bonjour merci merci monsieur le ministre
donc nous allons entamer le débat et je
rappelle la règle dont la suite du débat
chaque orateur oratrice dispose de deux
minutes maximum pour présenter sa
question avec une réponse du
gouvernement pour une durée équivalente
de deux minutes
dans le cas où l'auteur de la question
souhaite répliquer
il dispose de 30 secondes
supplémentaires à condition que le temps
initial de deux minutes n'est pas été
dépassé nous allons donc entamer le
débat et je passe tout de suite la
parole à madame florence blatrix compta
du groupe socialiste pour poser sa
question
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues depuis août
2000 va les salariés des entités est
filiale de suez et veolia sont inquiets
pour leur avenir les clients usagers et
autres contractant de ces groupes le
sont tout autant
c'est le cas des collectivités
territoriales dont nous sommes les
représentants dans les fonctions qui
sont les nôtres de parlementaires
nationaux en charge notamment du
contrôle des autorités exécutives
beaucoup de questions demeurent en
suspens sur l'attention et l'action des
pouvoirs publics et de l'état
actionnaire
nous avons constitué au sénat un groupe
de suivi de ce projet de fusion calé
j'ai l'honneur de participer
j'aimerais aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre gardés avec vous non pas vers
le passé mais vers à l'avenir de ces
deux groupes
nous avons deux groupes issus chacun
d'une longue et prestigieuse histoire
qui sont particulièrement performants en
france en europe et dans le monde
ils sont présents là et l'eau dans des
activités qui sont à maturité sur le
marché français et doivent pour se
développer et rester compétitif pouvoir
bénéficier de la dynamique du marché
mondial
le risque est grand pour l'entité dont
les activités seraient principalement
circonscrite en france de voir sa
pérennité à terme remise en cause
quel avenir en cas de fusion pour la
part de ses activités jugées moins
stratégiques et cd
même si elle échappait à la vente à la
découpe quelles dynamiques internes
auront elles coupent et des activités
avec lesquels elle développait des
synergies depuis la fin de l'été 2020
l'annnonce de la vente des parts d'
angie dans suez s'est suivie de
déclarations parfois discordantes de
l'état qu'elle était réellement alors la
stratégie de l'état actionnaire et son
levier opérationnel quelle agence des
participations de l'état
la paix at-elle fait connaître à angie
des demandes particulières en termes de
dividendes au de valorisation boursière
et comment l'état actionnaire en
ont-ils désormais agir pour réussir sa
médiation et assurer le développement à
l'international et en france de groupes
français performant efficace dans un
service essentiel à nos concitoyens
merci monsieur le ministre
la sénatrice merci de vous tourner
d'abord vers l'avenir ce que je pense
que c'est la bonne méthode ça à rien de
pleurer sur le lait renversé
mieux vaut essayer de voir ce qui peut
être construits à l'avenir
ma conviction reste la même aujourd'hui
il y à deux voies possibles dans les
semaines et dans les mois qui viennent
soit les deux entreprises qui sont deux
entreprises leurs appels privés
poursuivre dans la logique de
l'affrontement et je considère que cela
fera beaucoup de dégâts inutile encore
plus inutile dans cette période de crise
économique où les acteurs français
doivent se rassembler et jacquel chapka
faire preuve de sens des responsabilités
deux grands industriels français dans
cette poste de crise économique doivent
trouver un terrain d'entente et ne
doivent pas céder à la facilité du
conflit est-ce qu'il ya ensuite des
possibilités d'accord sur les bases que
vous indiquez oui ma réponse est oui et
trois fois oui il ya des possibilités de
maintenir deux grandes entreprises
industrielles de répartir des actifs
entre les uns et les autres est
incertain de propositions qui ont été
faites de part et d'autre je souhaite
que ces mains tendues de part et d'autre
soit saisie qu'on arrive à définir le
périmètre de veolia le périmètre de suez
que les acteurs s'entendent et qu'il
trouve un accord à l'amiable
c'est hautement préférable les données
sont chauds à table le choix appartient
maintenant aux dirigeants de veolia com
ou dirigeants de suez je pense qu'il
serait bon que sortent de nos débats
quelles que soient nos divergences sur
des points ou sur d'autres points
un message simple et clair à destination
de ces deux entreprises
nous voulons l'avoir de l'accord et nous
refusons la voie du conflit merci
monsieur le ministre
chers collègues vous disposez de 32
secondes
l'autre merci monsieur le ministre en
effet je pense qu'il faut qu'une
solution soit trouvée
il ne faut surtout pas oublier que de
nombreuses fusions se solde par un échec
environ 60% des cas ce sera un terrible
gâchis alors que nous disposons
actuellement de deux champions et la
richesse des entreprises leur vraie
capitale est aussi constitué des hommes
des femmes qui tous les jours ci
consacre et mon voeu le plus cher
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre c'est
que toutes celles et tous ceux qui font
aujourd'hui la richesse de suez et de
veolia ne soient pas abandonnées pour
une chimère merci chers collègues la
parole à notre collègue sophie primas
pour deux minutes maximum
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre merci de votre présence cet
après midi mais cher quel collègue
monsieur le ministre quelques mots quand
même sur le lait renversé
je ne veux pas et je ne peux pas croire
un instant que le sort de veolia et de
suez deux pépites françaises de surface
mondiale fusse-t-elle des entreprises
privées est été indifférent dans les
dernières années au président et je mets
les prises dont pluriel alors conseiller
économique au gouvernement que penser
soit que le gouvernement nous a pas fait
part des orientations définies qu'il
souhaitait pour cette ces deux groupes
soit et c'est pire que l'état n'a pas su
jouer son rôle et insister auprès de
véolia et comme l'a dit le président
caennais rope raid angie pour permettre
l'émergence d'offres alternatives la
précipitation des acteurs vous l'avais
dit la contradiction apparente au sein
même de l'état n'ont pas permis de
prendre ce recul et qu'elle destruction
de valeur en seulement quelques semaines
aujourd'hui les lignes bouger en creux
une négociation semble s'amorcer
peut-être à votre initiative d'ailleurs
autour de deux projets qui ont émergé
ces derniers jours mais en amputant suez
de ses activités à l'international ce
qui pour l'instant l'offre de veolia
nous pensons ici au sénat que ses deux
sauts potentiel d'innovation dans le
futur dont suez sera privée à son
détriment
au détriment des collectivités
territoriales et comme votre politique
est de permettre l'investissement
l'investissement et l'investissement
vous l'avez rappelé vous êtes évidemment
vous devez avoir un rôle dans ces
négociations
car il s'agit en fait de pro
gd compétitivité de services qui sont
des services stratégiques les services
de l'environnement
on ne peut pas monsieur le ministre
convoqué la convention citoyenne
on ne peut pas produire un projet de loi
climat résilience et pardonnez moi
l'expression accepter un bazar pareil
entre deux entreprises majeures
stratégique de l'environnement c'est
donc maintenant qu'il faut agir il
existe encore une fenêtre d'opportunité
jusqu'au 20 avril par une médiation de
l'état
comment vous services sont ils mobilisés
pour faire aboutir une solution qui soit
concertée qui soit ambitieuse qui soient
pérennes car vous avez raison
l'important c'est la vision que nous
partageons sur ses services fondamentaux
de l'environnement merci chaque collègue
monsieur le ministre mais madame la
présidente chère sophie primas la
première responsabilité de l'état
actionnaire
elle était à l'égard des jeeps à l'égard
de suez ou à l'égard de veolia qui sont
des entreprises strictement privée je le
rappelle donc nous notre souhait était
de permettre à angie de se développer de
se recentrer sur ses activités chacun
sait qu'elles gèrent un portefeuille
d'activité trop diversifié et qui était
nécessaire kenji puisse simplifier et
clarifier sa stratégie industrielle
nous avons d'ailleurs veiller aussi à ce
que le remplacement la direction
générale d -g se fasse dans de bonnes
conditions madame mcgregor aujourd'hui
fait un travail tout à fait remarquable
pour préciser ces stratégies d' angie
dans laquelle je le redis l'état est
actionnaire
donc il a une responsabilité
actionnariale ce n'est pas le cas pour
suez ou pour veolia ensuite nous avons
fixé un cadre général je le redis j'y
suis très attaché
c'est le maintien de la concurrence
c'est la préservation de l'emploi et
c'est la garantie sur les technologies
industrielles de pointe comme vous
l'avez dit qui doit présider au
rapprochement entre ces deux entreprises
est ce que l'état souhaite intervenir et
cherché à rapprocher les deux points de
vue ma réponse est oui
est-ce qu'il l'a fait oui nous avons
fait au début et nous avons continué à
le faire au cours des dernières semaines
puisque j'ai souhaité que le directeur
général du trésor puisse faire une
médiation entre les deux parties suez et
veolia discuter avec chacune des deux
parties et essayer de rapprocher les
deux positions
je suis reconnaissant directeur général
du trésor du travail qu'il a fait un
travail tout à fait remarquable pour
essayer de rapprocher les deux positions
mais je le redis l'état n'est pas partie
à cette négociation
il est là simplement pour servir
d'arbitré cherchait rapprocher les
positions
nous progressons ou venez de l'indiquer
j'espère que au bout du compte la raison
l'emportera et que les deux entreprises
comprendront que leurs intérêts leur
intérêt patrimonial leurs intérêts
industriels leur intérêt réputationnel
aussi et de trouver un accord à
l'amiable je vous répond très clairement
oui l'état à jouer son rôle pour
rapprocher les positions entre les deux
entreprises
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à notre collègue dany wattebled pour
deux minutes maximum malaisie merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministère collègues j'ai eu peur fois
l'occasion d'appeler à la renaissance
d'un véritable mystère de l'industrie un
monsieur qui est véritablement
exclusivement chargé de concevoir et
d'appliquer une stratégie un seul par
d'autres pays je me réjouis qu'un
collègue socialiste soit conscient d'un
site est de conserver prégnant le
patrimoine inscrire français est inscrit
ce débat à l'ordre du jour
malheureusement auparavant beaucoup de
gouvernements laisser-faire des roches à
des rachats de nos fleurons et la perte
progressive d'un précieux savoir faire
industriel pour ne citer que
quelques-uns technique
arcelor la perte d'autonomie et que la
vente de la branche énergie de d'alstom
et même une fusion qui était prévu qui
n'a malheureusement pas eu lieu entre
alstom et siemens
afin de préserver l'emploi et surtout de
maintenir les compétences industrielles
d'autres pays le gouvernement s'emploie
à créer nouvelle chaîne de valeur et
c'est à saluer au delà de son rôle dans
le développement d'une stratégie à long
terme
l'état doit être également attentifs aux
prises de contrôle des entreprises
françaises est sauvegardé nous savoir
faire technologique
si le pays a lancé par veolia et suez
aboutissait elle aurait pour effet de
fusionner l'activité internationale de
deux champions français
pourtant certains exemples de fusion
pose le problème des relations qui
suivent
au-delà de cette opération plusieurs
questions se posent pensez-vous le seul
ministre qu'un rapprochement de ce type
mais par principe en péril le patrimoine
industriel français le gouvernement at
il établi une liste des industries à
valeur stratégique qu'est le plan
d'action du gouvernement pour les
sauvegarder elle est développée
quel reconquête industrielle quelle
articulation avec nos partenaires
européens permettrait aux entreprises de
peser suffisamment sur la scène
internationale notamment vire des
recoupements du type airbus et enfin
quel sur les tailles opn quand nos
partenaires polonais achète des avions
de chasse américains ou quand nos
partenaires allemands formule des
exigences au sujet des durées l'avion de
chasse européen je vous remercie
merci chaque collègue monsieur le
ministre
oui merci monsieur le sénateur je pense
que peu de gouvernements
ce sont autant employés à protéger notre
industrie et protéger nos grandes
entreprises industrielles
quant à ce qu'au val était menacée de
fermeture
je suis battu pendant plus de deux ans
pour garder cette grande usine avec un
four électrique belle aciéries ouverte
trouver des repreneurs
dieu sait que ça a été les montagnes
russes avec désespoir des déceptions
mais au bout du compte nous avons sauver
l'aciérie d'ascq ovale et les 300
emplois qui vont avec
lorsque le groupe qui a repris à ce
qu'au val et hayange et d'autres
entreprises de l'aciérie en france s'est
trouvée confrontée à des difficultés
financières lundi dernier nous avons
débloqué 20 millions d'euros de prêts
pour permettre à ce qu'au val poursuivre
son activité
nous sommes intervenus pour favoriser le
rapprochement entre alstom et bombardier
qui permet de créer un leader dans le
domaine de l'industrie ferroviaire
je n'ai pas hésité ce qui peut être
surprenante de ma part a nationalisé les
chantiers de l'atlantique et nous avons
renoncé au rapprochement avec
fincantieri de concert avec notre
partenaire italien parce que nous
estimions que les conditions n'étaient
plus remplie lorsque l'acteur canadien
couche-tard à fait respectable par
ailleurs a voulu racheter carrefour dans
une opération il me semble précipité je
me suis opposé et je constate
aujourd'hui avec plaisir que finalement
carrefour n'était pas aussi mauvais état
que ça puisque carrefour vient de faire
une opération tout à fait admirable au
brésil en rachetant un certain nombre
d'actifs au brésil
j'en félicite la direction de carrefour
mais c'est bien la preuve qu'il n'y
avait aucune raison de céder ce géant la
distribution qui au passage était le
premier employeur privé français donc je
crois que nous intervenons à bon escient
pour protéger sans cesse les intérêts
stratégiques industriels de la nation
française et que les choses soient bien
claires je n'hésiterai pas à continuer à
le faire nous le faisons aussi pour être
offensif et créer de nouvelles chaînes
de valeur parce que c'est ça le grand
défi c'est pas simplement de protéger
c'est aussi d'investir et créer de
nouvelles chaînes de valeur vous citez
l'europe
je rappelle que sur les batteries
électriques sur l'hydrogène sur le
calcul quantique sur le cloud
nous créons de nouvelles chaînes de
valeur europe et c'est probablement l'un
des résultats les plus positifs de la
crise dont nous sommes en train de
sortir
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
désormais à notre collègue sophie taille
et pau lyon pour deux minutes maximum
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues on peut
s'interroger quand même sur ce qu'a fait
l'état dans les émois et qui ont précédé
notamment dans par rapport au rôle de la
de la caisse des dépôts et consignations
ça a été soulevée par mon collègue
gilles et est ce que la caisse des
dépôts et consignations a pour vocation
de se trouver partie prenante dans cet
opéra qui se révèle au style lorsque le
conseil d'administration de veolia la
décision de mélopées assez prise c'était
à l'unanimité et cette position donc de
la cdc s'est heurtée
la position de lagence participation de
l'état au conseil d'administration d'
angie
comment interpréter cette cette
incohérence ne serait-il pas de la
responsabilité aujourd'hui la cdc vous
parlez du directeur du trésor
mais est ce que là c'est la caisse des
dépôts et consignations étant le premier
actionnaire de veolia quand vous dites
veolia s'est totalement privé le premier
actionnaire c'est quand même la caisse
des dépôts et consignations donc n'y at
il pas là une voie qui permet aussi à un
moment donné de mettre les je dirais
l'intérêt général sur la table sur le
devant de la scène pour faire en sorte
que les choses se passent correctement
au bénéfice du service public et au
bénéfice des agents des personnels et
des usagers
parce que bien l'eau et les déchets
c'est quand même l'essentiel en termes
de services publics
merci chers collègues sur le ministre
oui la caisse des dépôts et
consignations effectivement 6% de
participation dans veolia mais je
rappelle que caisse des dépôts et
consignations est indépendante ne donne
pas d'instruction un directeur général
la caisse des dépôts et consignations
pour lui dire vous fait ceci ou vous
faites cela est déplacé je le rappelle
aussi sous le contrôle du parlement
ensuite je ne vais pas épiloguer sur un
sujet qui relève désormais du droit des
affaires et du droit privé je redis
simplement mais je ne vais pas la
répéter
quitte à vous lasser un trop grand
nombre de fois quelles sont les
conditions qui ferait de ce
rapprochement
un rapprochement utile d'un point de vue
industriel pour la nation française
préserver la concurrence préserver
l'emploi préserver l'empreinte
industriel c'est les conditions qui
doivent permettre à cette opération de
réussir et l'autre condition il me
semble nécessaire c'est que cela se
fasse sur la base d'un accord amiable
personne je le redis n'a d'intérêt à
engager un conflit ouvert entre deux
grands géants industriels et je verrais
tu dis très clairement la présidente
sophie primas nous sommes intervenus
pour pacifier les choses rapprocher les
positions des deux parties
je souhaite maintenant qu'elle écoute
la voie qui n'est pas simplement la voie
du bizet l'économie et des finances mais
qui est la voix des parlementaires telle
voix des représentants du peuple
français et je pense la voix très
majoritaire de nos compatriotes merci
monsieur mini short collègues vous avez
une minute
merci monsieur le président à leur
écoute et je joue vrai le site internet
de la caisse des dépôts et consignations
qui constitue je cite un grand pôle
financier public à l'identité forte est
ancrée dans l'histoire
à l'intersection du domaine privé et du
secteur public et du secteur privé
concurrentiel le groupe est entièrement
dédié au service de l'intérêt général
avec un objectif unique faire grandir la
france
alors je suppose que le conseil
d'administration de la cdc tout seul
dans son coin ne décide pas ce qu'est
l'intérêt général ni l'objectif de faire
grandir la france je suppose quand même
que ça doit être un petit peu en
relation avec le gouvernement de la
france je le pense d'ailleurs il ya des
parlementaires qui siègent en outre je
voudrais vous dire monsieur le ministre
que quand vous nous dites que vous tirer
comme conclusion de cette affaire que
finalement ça prouve que l'état n'a rien
à faire dans les conseils
d'administration type angie et autres et
qu'il doit uniquement ceux se concentrer
dans les services publics mais qu'est-ce
que donc que la fourniture d'électricité
pas seulement la production mais la
fourniture d'électricité où l'accès à
l'eau que des services publics je crois
au contraire qu'on doit réinterroger la
place mais en l'augmentant de l'état
dans ces entreprises
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à julien barjots tôt pour
deux minutes
merci monsieur le président depuis le 30
août 2020 nous assistons à une bataille
fratricide entre les deux géants de
traitement de l'eau autour d'un projet
de fusion entre veolia et suez
cette bataille est devenue une véritable
tragédie grecque à partir du moment où
angie est devenu favorable à l'offre
d'achat proposée par veolia malgré
l'opposition de l'état actionnaire
d'un côté veolia qui veut créer en
france le super champion mondial pour la
transformation écologique de l'aude suez
absolument opposé à tout projet de
fusion dans les termes proposés par
veolia salam pour ses 90 collaborateurs
dont trente mille en france et évoque
une menace de pertes d'emplois en
sous-main des fonds d'investissement
gravitent autour des deux géants
meridian à proximité de veolia qui ne
cesse de monter de montrer patte blanche
pour assurer les salaires
du suez et hardy en egypte autour de
suez visant à assurer l'indépendance et
l'intégrité du groupe entre ces deux
géants embarqué dans cette bataille un
grand nombre de communes françaises ne
cachent pas leur inquiétude
ce projet de fusion pourrait en effet
concerner toutes les collectivités qui
ont délégué la gestion de l'euro à l'un
ou à l'autre de ces deux groupes
à ce jour la situation paraît
difficilement conciliables et nous nous
acheminons vers des enchères boursière
pourtant face à des enjeux économiques
géopolitiques et environnementaux
majeurs
notre état stratège doit conforter son
rôle alors que la journée internationale
de l'eau était célébrée le 22 mars
dernier qu'un tiers de la population
mondiale n'a pas accès à l'eau salubre
quelles alternatives s'offrent à nous
pour régler une situation complexe
potentiellement préjudiciable en termes
d'emplois mais qui doit apporter une
réponse viable aux deux protagonistes et
permettent à la france de gagner
davantage de visibilité face à des
concurrents étrangers toujours plus
redoutable merci beaucoup merci cher
collègue monsieur le ministre faut
encore monsieur le sénateur bargeton je
veux pas me prononcer sur les offres d
un les offres des autres ou sommes dans
une économie où ce sont des acteurs
privés qui s'exprime et je redis que je
ne ménagerai pas mes efforts pour
parvenir à concilier les positions des
uns et des autres la vraie question
c'est de savoir s'il ya de l'espace pour
deux grands acteurs industriels la
gestion des déchets et du traitement de
l'eau et nous notre réponse est oui il y
a de la place pour ces deux grands
acteurs
est-ce que c'est mieux que d'avoir un
seul acteur industriel
nous nous considérons qu avoir de la
concurrence notamment pour les
collectivités locales que vous
représentez ici c'est quelque chose que
vous lever indiqué monsieur le sénateur
de positif ça ouvre des choix ça ouvre
des possibilités pour les collectivités
locales auquel vous êtes légitimement
très attaché il y a eu des progrès dans
le rapprochement des positions
au cours des derniers jours nous allons
continuer à travailler dans ce sens
large qui va vous donner de garanties à
l'heure où je vous parle que tout cela
aboutira à un accord en bonne et due
forme entre
les deux parties mais je pense une fois
encore qu'il est préférable pour tous
merci au public
donc la parole à notre collègue maryse
carrère pour deux minutes maximum merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il y as
exactement un an aurait pu aurait dû
débuter la privatisation du groupe
aéroports de paris
conformément aux articles 130 à 136 de
la loi pacte après le rejet de cette
réforme par le sénat en 2018 un projet
de référendum d'initiative partagée
avait été proposée pour la première fois
par des parlementaires recueillant de
plus d'un million de signataires
l'ironie de l'histoire veut que ce soit
la crise du coc vite qui est enterré ce
projet contesté après une année de
pandémie ces débats apparaissent
ancienne plus récemment vous avez
monsieur ministre pris la décision
d'empêcher un projet de fusion entre
l'entreprise carrefour et le groupe de
supérettes canadienne couche tard si le
caractère stratégique de cette décision
a pu étonner
il est vrai que l'enjeu n'est pas tout à
fait négligeable en terme d'emploi avec
plus de 300 mille salariés concernés le
cas de veolia suez est un peu différent
puisqu'il s'agit d'une offre publique
d'achat entre deux entreprises
concurrentes mais française dans un
secteur qui intéresse de nombreux
acteurs entreprises de salariés
consommateurs et élus locaux
l'examen de la loi pacte avait aussi été
l'occasion de débattre de la notion
d'entreprise stratégique avec le
renforcement des pouvoirs de contrôle du
ministère de l'économie sur les
autorisations d'investissements
étrangers dans certains secteurs
d'activité
ma question est donc double à l'aune du
présent car veolia suez mais aussi des
exemples précis c'est précités
pourriez-vous préciser ce que le
gouvernement considère ou non comme une
entreprise ou un secteur stratégique et
où il peut avoir vocation à intervenir
et deuxième question dans quelle mesure
nos conceptions française en la matière
peuvent-elles entrer en conflit avec les
régulateurs européens
on sait en effet combien la commission
et la cour de justice de l'union
européenne peuvent être soucieuse du
respect des règles de libre concurrence
une fusion d'eolia suez représentent
elles un risque en la matière je vous
remercie
merci chaque collègue monsieur le
ministre
oui je vais revenir une seconde sur le
projet de rachat de carrefour par couche
tard
si cette décision était à reprendre
demain jeu reprendra exactement la même
pourquoi d'abord on m'explique que ce
n'est pas stratégique mais le nucléaire
est stratégique
la défense et stratégique des
technologies de pointe sont stratégiques
mais notre alimentation est tout aussi
stratégique
le stratégique c'est pas forcément ce
qui est loin des gens ce qui est à
distance que technologiquement de pointe
le stratégique c'est aussi ce qui
préserve notre culture notre manière de
vivre la qualité notre alimentation
notre sécurité sanitaire et c'est bien
ce qui est en jeu dans la grande
distribution car je rappelle que les
grands distributeurs français ont créé
un modèle dont ils peuvent être fiers
d'approvisionnement auprès des filières
agricoles françaises qui ici peut me
garantir que le rachat de couche-tard de
carrefour aurait préservé les filières
agricoles françaises
est ce que quelqu'un peut prendre cet
engagement de prendre cette
responsabilité
moi je ne le pouvait pas donc j'ai
manifesté mon but est ce que par
ailleurs vous pensez que les états unis
accepterait que l'un de leurs premiers
employeurs privés par exemple wall mart
se fasse racheter par un grand
distributeur français sans coup férir
probablement non et est ce que vous
pensez
enfin qui ne vaut pas mieux respecter
les procédures telles qu'elles sont
définies par vous même c'est à dire par
le législateur il y à un décret ce
investissements étrangers en france vous
en avez et nous en avons tous ensemble
élargit le champ d'application et toutes
les entreprises tout qui veulent faire
un investissement en france et qui
savent qu'elle touche à une technologie
sensible une activité qui critique
elles viennent d'abord discuter avec
l'état français pour savoir si cet
investissement est bienvenu ou pas ses
275 procédure dont j'ai parlé
précédemment
à partir du moment où un groupe
s'affranchit des procédures que vous
même vous avez défini où les
législateurs
c'est ma responsabilité de mise de
l'économie et des finances de dire non
protégés ça n'est pas un gros mot et je
constate une fois encore que carrefour a
montré ses capacités de rebond avec
l'opération qu'elle vient de lancer au
brésil
j'en félicite la direction de carrefour
j'en félicite les salariés de carrefour
car c'est bien la preuve que ce groupe a
su se réinventer et a su innover au
cours des derniers mois chers collègues
vous souhaitez une réplique vous avez du
temps encore non merci monsieur le
ministre je conteste absolument pas fait
que votre démarche sur carrefour et ce
groupe canadien se soit vous ayez pris
cette décision là en tout cas s'il ya
bien un secteur stratégique aussi et
qu'on peut considérer sa stratégie que
ces cas quand il concerne près de 300000
emplois en france et je pense que ça
mérite de la protection de la part de
l'état merci merci chers collègues la
parole est à notre collègue fabien gay
pour deux minutes maximum merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre la
question du débat aurait pu être à quoi
joue l'état ou plutôt l'exécutif dans la
sphère suez veolia cela fait maintenant
plusieurs mois que nous assistons à une
mauvaise partie de monopoly le premier
coup d c'était la privatisation des
logis avec la loi pacte qui elle même va
être scindée en deux avec le plan
clamadieu comme edf avec le plan
hercules pour qu'une partie de ces
activités soient revendus à total puis
vous avez enchaîné avec la vente des
parts de suez
pourtant le stratégique que possédait un
que j avais au lia qui crasse à ce
cadeau a pu lancer son opa hostile
l'enjeu de la partie consiste à gérer la
majeure partie de l'or bleu de notre
pays celle des déchets et des services à
l'environnement
indispensable pour assurer la transition
écologique comment expliquer ou comment
croire que le projet d'absorption de
suez et puisse surprendre par sa
rapidité d'exécution les temps à la fois
comme puissance publique et comme
actionnaires d' angie mais aussi de
veolia puisque la caisse des dépôts en
est le premier actionnaire après alstom
nokia technique
angie general electric les chantiers de
l'atlantique la volonté de privatiser
adp est de casser odf
si aujourd'hui le démantèlement d'un
champion français de la transition
écologique auquel nous assistons il est
à noter d'ailleurs que vous avez en
horreur les monopoles lorsqu'ils sont
publiques et que vous organisez la
concurrence en revanche ça ne vous
dérange absolument pas que des monopoles
privés se constitue au seul profit des
actionnaires et au détriment des usagers
des salariés et des collectivités dès
lors la seule question est quand
l'exécutif décidera t-il d'arrêter la
grande braderie afin de permettre à
l'état de jouer son rôle de garant de
l'intérêt général
deux stratèges et d'actionnaires et en
tant que biens communs l'eau ne
devrait-elle pas faire partie des
secteurs stratégiques placer en dehors
des lois du marché comme l'avait rappelé
le président de macron pour ainsi oeuvré
à la création d'un grand service public
de l'eau qui lui soit dédié je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues monsieur le
ministre
oui la grande baradei monsieur le
sénateur nous coûte cher puisque nous
rachetons au contraire un certain nombre
d'actifs et nous prônons des positions
vous avez cité des chantiers de
l'atlantique je rappelle que désormais
les chantiers de l'atlantique sont à 85
% sous contrôle public
j'appelle pas ça de la braderie sur la
skoda et ayant jeu ont pris des
positions aussi pour protéger cette
entreprise et je pourrais multiplier les
exemples dans lesquelles les
interventions de l'état ont permis de
protéger notre outil industriel juges
rappellent simplement aussi que
lorsqu'on dégage 330 milliards d'euros
de prêts garantis par l'état pour
soutenir notre économie c'est encore la
meilleure façon d'éviter la braderie que
vous redoutez vous avez évoqué edf et
donc je veux répondre aussi à vos
inquiétudes sur ce sujet là on voit bien
que dans des défis considérables du
point de vue énergétique dans les années
à venir
c'est l'électrification des usages il
faut que nous bénéficions d'électricité
un coût raisonnable immédiatement
disponibles et edf a un rôle fondamental
à jouer là dessus
la transformation d'edf que nous
appelons de nos voeux elle vise
simplement à maintenir un prix de
l'énergie qui soit suffisamment rentable
pour l'entreprise de façon à ce qu'elle
puisse investir mais où
mais cette régulation je rappelle que si
jamais nous n'intervenons pas abandonnée
elle s'arrête parce qu'il ya des doigts
qu'il ya des règlements donc nous nous
battons pour maintenir cette régulation
des prix de l'énergie
vous devriez nous en être reconnaissants
nous nous maintenons pour nous nous
battons pour maintenir l'unité d'edf ce
grand service public de l'énergie vous
devriez nous en être reconnaissants et
nous nous battons pour préserver le
nucléaire car je crois à l'énergie
nucléaire
je pense que c'est une énergie qui est
indispensable pour disposer
d'électricité qui soit un coût
raisonnable faiblement émettrices de co2
est capable d'alimenter tous les usages
qui vont venir industriel avec
l'hydrogène ou privés avec la voiture
électrique ou d'autres usages
électriques
nous sommes en négociation avec la
commission européenne sur ce sujet la
négociation continue à progresser
vous m'avez interrogé pour savoir si je
suis prêt à recevoir les syndicats d'edf
pour discuter avec de nos propositions
ma porte est toujours ouverte
je recevrai les syndicats d'edf avec la
ministre de transition écologique dans
les jours qui viennent pour expliquer
aux syndicats
quelles sont nos intentions et nos
ambitions pour edf
écoutez leurs critiques écouter leurs
propositions et bâtir ensemble le
meilleur projet possible pour rodez
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à notre collègue jean pierre moga pour
l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues nous sommes attachés à la
constitution de champions nationaux et
européens afin de peser sur la
compétition internationale c'est
d'ailleurs le principal argument utilisé
par les promoteurs de la fusion entre
des entreprises numéro 1 et le numéro
deux du secteur du retraitement des
déchets et de l'eau toutefois une
éventualité n'est que peu évoqués ou
documenté
c'est le consistant à un veto de la part
des autorités de concurrence européennes
qui auront à traiter cette affaire de
manière similaire au veto mis pour la
fusion alstom siemens à février 2019
il est rare
que de tels mariages entre deux acteurs
d un champion dans un domaine soit
autorisée or trois arguments allant dans
ce sens pourrait être prise en compte
premièrement l'exigence de
désinvestissement pour qu'une telle
fusion se réalise ce qui réduirait
d'autant sa pertinence deuxièmement et
certaines de mes collègues l'ont évoqué
le fait que les deux parties les parties
prenantes au premier rang desquels
figurent les collectivités territoriales
souligne à raison les bienfaits de la
concurrence en termes de prix et de
qualité de service
troisièmement les inquiétudes en termes
d'emploi de valeur et les bienfaits
potentiellement surestimé d'une
croissance par la taille critique par
l'innovation et la signature de nouveaux
marchés pour deux acteurs tricolore
complémentaires sur la scène
internationale alors que l'idée défendue
par la france d'une réforme du règlement
européen les concentrations n'est pas
l'ordre du jour alors que la méfiance
européenne des grands groupes et
d'actualité comme le démontre le cas
d'edf
où en êtes vous monsieur le ministre de
vos discussions
partagez-vous des inquiétudes pardon
donne éventuel veto européen
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
oui mais le sénateur m'interrogeais en
fait sur deux questions liées mais
différente
d'abord sur la concurrence et le
maintien de la concurrence entre veolia
et suez je le redis nous sommes attachés
au maintien de la concurrence
ce projet de rapprochement pose des
difficultés du point de vue de la
concurrence en tout cas peut en poser
j'ai eu l'occasion d'en parler avec la
commissaire européenne en charge de la
concurrence madame vesta guerre et je
continuerai à discuter avec elles des
sujets de concurrence que pose le projet
de veolia
par rapport à ce s et ne l'oublions pas
c'est au bout du compte la commission
européenne qui donnera ou non son feu
vert à cette opération est donc légitime
que je sois en contact régulier avec la
commission européenne sur ce point
puisque vous tous ici avait appelé
justement au maintien d'une saine
concurrence dans le domaine du
traitement des déchets et de la gestion
de l'eau vous pouvez comptez donc sur la
mobilisation et ma très grande attention
avec la commission européenne sur ce
sujet ensuite l'autre sujet plus globale
c'est le maintien d'un cadre
concurrentiel qui soit adaptée à la
réalité de la situation économique
mondiale c'est des demandes que nous
avons fait avec mon homologue allemand
peter altmaier il y a quelques mois à
l'occasion du projet de fusion de
siemens et alstom pour dire qu'il
fallait un cadre plus global sur les
marchés pertinents
et il analyse à la fois mondiale et
dynamique des marchés
donc nous continuons à défendre cette
nouvelle approche droit de la
concurrence en europe
il est aujourd'hui plus pertinent
d'avoir une approche des marchés au
niveau mondial plutôt qu'une approche
locale et les plus pertinents avoir une
approche dynamique avant une approche
tactique surtout quand on voit la
rapidité avec laquelle nos concurrents
étrangers peuvent monter en gamme est
monté en puissance pour tous
continueront à défendre ces deux points
auprès de la commission européenne
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
notre collègue rachid tu es mal
merci monsieur président le ministre mes
chers collègues depuis sept mois
maintenant le capitalisme à la française
se déchirent par médias interposés
devant les tribunaux depuis sept mois
maintenant les salariés de suez veolia
sont inquiets pour leur avenir depuis
sept mois maintenant les collectivités
qui doivent renouveler leurs contrats
s'interrogent depuis sept mois
maintenant l'image et deux champions
français s'abîme sur la scène
internationale depuis sept mois
finalement seuls les banquiers
d'affaires et les avocats se frotte les
mains
il faut désormais en sortir de cette
crise collectivement aussi cet après
midi je vous propose modestement une
solution de sortie de crise demandons
salariés de véolia de suez pardon devant
donc salariés de suez via son
intersyndicale de construire et de
soumettre publiquement un cahier des
charges aux actionnaires actuels et
futurs ce cas des charges porterait
notamment sur les garanties sociales et
sur les effectifs la participation des
salariés au capital de l'entreprise
l'investissement des activités dans les
activités et dans les métiers de demain
la présence d'actifs en france et à
l'international en assurer la pérennité
le tenant du futur groupe suez des
activités sur le tout le territoire le
partenariat avec les collectivités et le
service aux usagers ainsi que la crainte
de la création d'une fiducie
garantissant la tenue des engagements
cette démarche public tourné vers
l'avenir qui se garde qu'ils soient
garantis par le parlement et l'état et
donc sur la table
aussi monsieur le ministre est dit prêt
à soutenir publiquement cette démarche
de cahier des charges et de
rassemblement merci cher collègue
monsieur le ministre mais monsieur le
sénateur c'est une démarche qui est
assez proche de la nôtre dans le fond
puisque ce que je vous présente depuis
le début de notre débat c'est bien un
cahier des charges et décharges qui vise
à faire de cette opération un succès et
pas un déchirement entre deux grandes
entreprises françaises maintien de la
concurrence préservation des emplois
préservation de l'empreinte industriels
voient le cahier des charges que nous
proposons je pense que nos positions
sont assez proches à leur rejoignent
aussi je crois les préoccupations des
salariés de suez qui l'ont exprimé à
plusieurs reprises maintenant c'est à
ces deux entreprises qui je le rappelle
sont des entreprises privées de se
saisir de ce cadre global
et d'en faire un autre merci je t'ai mal
reçu deux minutes peuvent bien sûr
monsieur mais s'il ya une différence
entre votre proposition est la mienne la
différence c'est que depuis maintenant
sept mois
malheureusement le rôle de l'état est
apparu assez abscons et depuis 7 - votre
voix n'est plus audible
ce que je vous propose à la différence
entre vous et moi la seconde c'est que
je propose que soient les salariés
eux-mêmes qui rédige le cahier des
charges et que vous en tant qu'etat nous
en temps parlementaire nous sur les
garantir les accompagner donc je
renouvelle jeunes n'ont pas la même
proposition pas la même démarche et donc
si vous pouviez vous nous dites que vous
êtes d'accord avec le cas des charges
propose d'ailleurs de vous soumettre ce
laïc nous pourrons donc avancer dans
l'intérêt des salariés de suez et veolia
si on est d'accord
merci chers collègues la parole est
désormais à notre collègue alain cadec
pour deux minutes maximum
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues gaulliste canal
historique vous ne connaissez monsieur
le ministre je suis attaché au principe
de l'intervention de la puissance
publique
quand il s'agit de défendre l'intérêt de
la nation et de ce qui reste de son
patrimoine industriel
nous avons là deux champions européens
dans le domaine de l'eau de
l'assainissement et du traitement des
déchets qui dans le cadre d'une juste
concurrence assure à nos collectivités
de pouvoir les mettre en compétition
pour leur délégation de service public
aujourd'hui veolia à lance une opa
hostile sur le groupe suez
après avoir racheté 29% du cas du
capital de cette société un angie avec
la bénédiction du gouvernement ne vous
en déplaise
on nous explique que ce rachat
déboucherait sur la création d'un
champion mondial dans le domaine
ne serait-il pas plus pertinent de
garder deux champions nationaux voire
européen
ce que propose d'ailleurs suez dans une
solution qui seraient négociés
rappelez vous monsieur le ministre des
soi-disant champions européens ou
mondiaux que nous devions créer avec le
rapprochement d'alstom et de general
electric ou encore d'alcatel et de nokia
soutenu à l'époque par notre président
de la république à leur ministre on sait
ce qu'il en est advenu à cette logique
de fusion absorption systématique
je préfère la saine concurrence qui
renforce la créa tic et la créativité
l'innovation et l'investissement massif
en recherche et développement
je ne prendrai que deux exemples comment
contester le statut de leader des
groupes lvmh et kering comment contester
le statut de leader des groupes edf et
angie pourtant concurrents en france
monsieur le ministre je crains qu'en
termes de vision stratégique économique
pour notre pays le gouvernement suive la
même pente que pour la gestion de la
crise sanitaire
improvisation changement erratique et
absence de cap
comment expliquer aux français que
l'état n'intervient pas dans la cession
des parts kenji possédait dans suez
ouvrant la porte à la fusion entre les
deux sociétés et que vous réclamiez
ensuite le maintien des deux leaders la
protection de l'emploi et la
préservation intégrale de la concurrence
toujours le en même temps où l état
stratège
monsieur le ministre une bonne fois pour
toutes
quelle est votre position sur ce dossier
merci cher collègue monsieur le ministre
et de gaulliste à gaullisme monsieur
cadec nous défendons la même position
c'est la préservation d'une concurrence
entre deux champions industriels
français je les dis depuis le début de
ce débat je pense que c'est la bonne
option
c'est celle qui permettra de préserver
la concurrence celle qui permettra de
préserver le plus grand nombre d'emplois
et celle qui permettra aussi de créer la
compétition nécessaire y compris du
point de vue des technologies et des
usages
vous voyez que nous rejoignons sur ce
point sur la stratégie de l'état je
pense qu'elle est extraordinairement
claire garantir la reconquête
industrielle du pays
nous sommes la seule majorité depuis des
années avoir réussi à recréer des
emplois industriels dans notre pays
favoriser des rapprochements lorsqu'ils
sont pertinents qu'ils donnent des
résultats notamment sur les technologies
critiques
on l'a fait par exemple sur les
microprocesseurs avec lester micro qui
est une très belle entreprise franco
italienne qui fonctionnent très bien on
l'a fait dans d'autres domaines celui
l'optique avec essilor du taudis cas
c'est un rapprochement qui fonctionne
remarquablement bien et que nous
soutenons
on vient de le voir avec alstom
bombardier qui est la preuve que dans
ces secteurs du transport ferroviaire
nous avons des atouts qui sont
absolument considérable donc lorsque
nous pouvons consolider renforcer nos
positions nous le faisons c'est un des
éléments clés de la stratégie quand il
faut s'opposer parce qu'on estime qu'il
a et technologies clés qui sont en jeu
nous le faisons aussi mais sans aucune
hésitation j'ai cité plusieurs exemples
au cours du débat j'en rajouterais juste
un c'est la session de photo nice à un
leader américain parfaitement
respectable par ailleurs et qui est un
partenaire régulier de la france mais
nous avons estimé que en matière de
vision nocturne
photo nice et est un élément stratégique
avec la ministre des armées florence
parly nous sommes opposés la session de
photo nice donc c'est le deuxième volet
de la stratégie refuser la cession de
technologie lorsque nous estimons que
elles appartiennent à la souveraineté
nationale et le troisième élément de la
stratégie je le redis je les dis dans
mon intervention liminaire
c'est favoriser l'investissement la
recherche l'innovation parce que c'est
encore ça qui permet le mieux à nos
industriels de réussir merci monsieur le
ministre la parole est maintenant à
notre collègue jean paul prince pour
deux minutes maximum merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues le projet de perdre veolia
suez s'il venait à être concrétisés
risquerait d'avoir des conséquences pour
de nombreuses collectivités dans leurs
délégations de services publics d'eau et
d'assainissement
une telle fusion aurait de nombreuses
conséquences sur le plan économique elle
pourrait en premier lieu avoir des
retombées positives en particulier les
économies d'échelle qui en résulteraient
pourrait faire baisser le coût des
prestations effectuées par l'entreprise
unique ainsi créée mais je redoute que
ce soit linverse qui se produisent dans
notre pays
en effet de par leur taille et leur
niveau de compétence dans ce domaine
veolia et suez sur des candidats
incontournable à ses délégations et bien
souvent les seuls mon inquiétude est la
fusion de ces deux entreprises
mettre fin à une saine concurrence dont
profitait jusqu'ici de nombreuses
collectivités et au final l'abonné
locale une entreprise géante en
situation de monopole aurait à pouvoir
de marché très fort trop fort pour de
nombreuses collectivités délégataires
dont elle serait la seule cocontractant
possible et ma crainte est que la
création de ce géant mondial se
traduisent pour elle et nos concitoyens
par une augmentation des prix diverses
pistes assez contradictoires ont d'ores
et déjà été évoquée pour éviter cette
situation
veolia récemment proposé de céder les
actions françaises de suez
en cas de fusion après avoir déclaré
avoir reçu des offres d'acquisition de
ses activités françaises dans le domaine
de l'eau et des déchets suez a annoncé
il ya quelques jours avoir rendu
incessibles par le biais d'une formation
ses deux principales sociétés d'eau en
france jusqu'en 2024
veolia alors annoncé saisir la justice
au milieu de cette bataille juridique
financières boursières l'état paraît
adopté une position de simple
observateur et le brouillard est totale
pour de nombreuses collectivités
délégataires
je suis sûr que vous êtes monsieur le
ministre
parfaitement au fait de ces enjeux je
souhaiterais savoir quelle est la
position de l'état sur cette question
particulièrement sensible pour les
collectivités de notre pays
merci sert collègue monsieur le ministre
monsieur sénateurs si nous avons fait
des efforts de rapprochement des
positions des deux entreprises c'est
précisément parce que nous sommes
conscients des enjeux en termes de
concurrence de prix pour les
collectivités locales d'accès à ces
services
donc je partage totalement l'analyse qui
est la vôtre considère qu'il est mieux
de garder cette concurrence c'est pour
cela que nous sommes intervenus même
s'il s'agit de deux entreprises privées
derrière il ya des enjeux qui sont des
enjeux publics qui sont l'accès à l'eau
l'accès à la gestion des déchets et que
de ce point de vue là il est mieux et
plus sain de garder une concurrence
entre les deux acteurs je rappelle
également qu'au delà de la médiation
dont j'ai parlé
la présidente de sophie primas nous
avons engagé un dialogue avec la
commission européenne qui est chargée de
l'examen au titre du droit de la
concurrence de cette opération et je
redis que in fine et c'est bien la
commission européenne qui donnera son
feu vert ou non à cette opération du
point de vue du droit de la concurrence
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis en
contact régulier avec la commissaire
margaret vesta guerre sur ce sujet comme
sur d'autres
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
notre collègue viviane artigalas pour
deux minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le projet
de fusion veolia suez inquiète à juste
titre les élus locaux ça vient d'être
dit qu'ils redoutent la création d'une
situation de monopole sur la gestion de
l'eau et des déchets premier poste de
dépenses des collectivités locales
certes le pdg de veolia rappelé qu'une
superposition des activités eau de
veolia et de suez serait impossible
aussi pour éviter cet écueil aux yeux
des autorités de la concurrence
le rapprochement des deux entreprises
permettrait de créer une nouvelle entité
rassemblant l'ensemble des activités eau
de suez ce qui en ferait le troisième
opérateur mondial de la gestion de l'eau
l'autre inquiétude concerne la
préservation des emplois d'ingénierie et
de sciez et des sièges mais veolia
soutient qu en plus de conserver les
deux masses salariales
l'entreprise continuera d'embauché on
nous présente donc un projet qui semble
fournir toutes les garanties demandées
pas de situation de monopole pas de
suppression d'emplois et même
l'obligation pour les parties prenantes
de s'engager devant les parlementaires
qui auront un droit de contrôle et de
sanction sur les engagements non tenus
cependant les élus locaux ne paraissent
pas rassuré par ses déclarations faites
par le pdg de veolia en achever la
situation de concurrence actuelle leur
permet d'obtenir des conditions de
contractualisation favorable face à un
groupe unique en situation de monopole
ce qui adviendrait si la fusion avec
suez aboutisse et les élus craignent
d'être désavantagés et de voir leur
marge de manoeuvre fortement réduite
or compte tenu d'un contexte budgétaire
extrêmement contraint que subissaient
les collectivités depuis déjà plusieurs
années le fait qu'un monopole s'exerce
sur les marchés de l'eau et des déchets
risquerait de gréve et encore davantage
leur budget de fonctionnement
monsieur le ministre
comment l'état stratège entente il
répondre concrètement à ces deux
légitimes inquiétudes et intervenir dans
ce dossier afin de garantir à la fois
une saine concurrence dans les
territoires et le maintien des emplois
existants
merci chaque collègue monsieur le
ministre mais je suis désolé de risquer
de vous ennuyer par la répétition des
mêmes propos mais sans rentrer dans le
détail des questions que vous posez
qu'il nous faut encore relèvent du droit
des affaires qui m'empêche d'aller plus
loin dans les réponses que je pourrais
vous faire ce que je veux fixer avec
vous aujourd'hui c'est le cadre de la
discussion
et toutes les questions que vous avez
soulevé proviennent quasiment toutes à
deux questions fondamentales sur
lesquelles je crois qu'il ya un accord
global qui se dégage la première c'est
qu'il vaut mieux avoir une seule
entreprise qui concentrent l'intégralité
de l'offre en matière de gestion des
déchets de l'eau la réponse est
unanimement non vous voulez de la
concurrence et nous voulons aussi de la
concurrence
je pense qu'elle est saine je pense
qu'elle est nécessaire notamment pour
les québec tivité locale deuxième grande
question que vous posez tout ce que je
crois que nous apportons tous très
majoritairement la même réponse c'est
faut-il que cette opération se fasse par
une opération inamicale hostiles ou au
contraire par une entente entre les deux
groupes je crois que nous sommes tous
ici unanimement favorable à ce qu'il y
ait un accord soit trouvé entre les deux
groupes sur une base amiable et je
souhaite que les propos que nous avons
tous tenus ici
à l'occasion de ce débat est un débat
particulièrement utiles soient transmis
aux présidents des deux groupes pour
leur dire trouver un terrain d'accord
entre vous parce que l'image que cela
renvoie pour l'industrie française
l'image que cela renvoie pour la place
de paris n'est pas une image positive
chers collègues vous pouvez vous avez
conduisons oui merci monsieur le
ministre je vois bien oui que nous avons
tous cette volonté de maintenir cette
saine concurrence simplement vous nous
renvoyez à des moyens qui ne sont pas
qui ne sont pas sur or les élus locaux
ils ont besoin de garanties fiables plus
en groupe et vaste - la concurrence peut
s'exercer sainement l'état doit vraiment
intervenir sur ce point vous devez avoir
des moyens de pression sur ces deux pdg
qui restent sur leurs positions tous les
deux nous avons bien vu que des
précédents projets de fusions et de
rachats une fois réalisés ont pu générer
de très mauvaises surprises ça déjà
aussi ôté des 10 en faire sur la
question du maintien des emplois il est
urgent que l'état demande à veolia de
présenter rapidement les conséquences de
son projet sur les sites de production
territoire par territoire
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est désormais un autre
collègue gilbert fabre au monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
chers collègues dans un pays fortement
centralisé comme la france la question
du rôle de l'état actionnaire sport se
pose forcément après une alternance au
xxème siècle deux périodes de forte
nationalisation et de périodes de
privatisation le portefeuille des
entreprises à participation publique
reste important mais l'actuel qui
récente montre que l'état n'a pas
toujours été efficace dans son rôle de
protecteurs du patrimoine économique et
industrielle de la france
on peut citer sans être exhaustif son
rôle récent dans quelques unes des
principales entreprises cotées en bourse
le crédit lyonnais les asf gaz de france
france télécom et plus récemment alstom
alors que le rôle de l'état consiste
traditionnellement soit accompagné le
développement des filières stratégiques
soit sauvé les fleurons de l'industrie
française
la sphère suez veolia doit de nous
interroger
monsieur le ministre votre propre aveu
vous avez été vaccinés avec suez veolia
contre la participation de l'état au
capital des entreprises
c'est une déclaration vous avez fait un
journaliste du figaro
mais cela ne vous a pas eu unis
immunisés contre la tentation des
interventions de l'état est l'exemple le
plus récent est la sphère couche-tard
carrefour mais dans cette affaire l'état
semble avoir été beaucoup plus efficace
puisque vous avez et vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure tout simplement menacé
d'utiliser le décret sur les
investissements en france dans ces
conditions
ne doit-on pas se demander si l'état
doit rester l'état actionnaire et
conserver toutes les participations
qu'il a actuellement
n'aurait-il pas intérêt à revoir sa
stratégie dans deux directions
complémentaires
d'une part en usant du pouvoir de l'état
régalien pour infléchir certaines
décisions
c'est ce qui a été fait dans le cas de
la sphère carrefour d'autre part en
réorientant tout ou partie de ses
participations dans des domaines qui
derk détermineront l'avenir des français
je pense à la santé est naturellement au
laboratoire sanofi je pense aux
nouvelles technologies et à la maîtrise
de la 5g par wei et je pense enfin à
toutes les technologies qui
permettraient d'améliorer notre
environnement pour écrire vous apposez
votre liste monsieur le ministre je suis
très heureux monsieur sénateurs que nous
puissions avoir ce débat au delà de la
sphère suez veolia sur la place de
l'état dans l'économie c'est un sujet de
débat majeur il a été encore renforcée
par la crise économique où l'état a joué
un rôle de protection comme il n'avait
pas joué depuis des décennies mais au
moment où nous sortirons cette crise
économique je crois qu'il est très
important de définir clairement devant
nos compatriotes
ce que nous attendons de l'état dans
l'économie pour moi je le redis la trois
fonctions essentielles qui rejoignent
les propos que vous avez tenus le
premier rôle est un rôle de protection
l'état est là pour protéger il a pour
protéger l'ordre public économique et
lorsqu'on voit que l'ordre public
économique n'est pas respecté l'état est
là pour dire le droit et faire respecter
l'ordre public économique notamment pour
les plus fragiles et notamment pour les
salariés protégés c'est je le redis
protéger notre nation contre les
investissements de pillage
les investissements qui ne sont là que
pour récupérer nos technologies nos
startups ne savoir faire sur lesquels
nous avons investi depuis des décennies
ne sont pas les bienvenus c'est les
investissements durables
créateur d'emplois et créateur de
richesses qui sont les bienvenus en
france qui font de notre nation la
nation la plus attractive aux
investissements étrangers en europe sa
deuxième responsabilités je le redis ça
répond aussi à d'autres questions qui
ont été posées c'est de garantir la
pérennité la solidité de service public
qui font partie de notre culture
économique et qui sont une fierté pour
notre nation nous avons dégagé dans le
plan de relance 20 milliards d'euros aux
entreprises publiques
nous avons aidé air france nous avons
aidé renault nous avons aidés et nous
continuerons à aider la sncf 4,5
milliards d'euros ça fait partie des
premières sommes qui ont été décaissés
pour la sncf dans le cadre du plan de
relance
nous croyons au service public et nous
les soutenons et la troisième
responsabilités vous venez de l'indiquer
je crois que c'est absolument majeur
c'est le développement de nouvelles
filières industrielles qui ne serait pas
rentable sans le soutien de l'état si
l'état ne soutient pas le développement
de batteries électriques
il n'y aura pas de batterie électrique
nous continuerons à des pontes de la
chine et de l'asie
si l'état ne soutient pas le
développement de semi conducteurs
stmicroelectronics a développé de semi
conducteurs parce que l'investissement
coûte trop cher et n'est pas rentable
si nous ne soutenons pas massivement le
développement de la filière hydrogène
vu le coût l'hydrogène aujourd'hui aucun
acteur privé niera tout seul parce qu'il
ne sera pas rentable dans les 5 ou dans
les dix prochaines années
donc il faut le soutien de l'état pour
développer cette nouvelle filière
industrielle et je me réjouis que nous
développions davantage en un an de
filière industrielle en france en europe
que tout ce que nous avons fait depuis
20 ans merci monsieur le ministre la
parole est désormais à stéphane sous
tard elle pour deux minutes
si monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues que des
entreprises va y conduire des stratégies
de croissance et de développement d'un
grand groupe veut devenir le champion
mondial des services dans le domaine de
l'environnement
quoi de plus normal mais l'état
actionnaire l'état régulateur l'état
stratège
quel coup venait encore de le redéfinir
et je penche partage des orientations un
rôle à jouer et une place à tenir pour
veiller à l'équilibré et à la durabilité
de telles opérations
cette opa amicale devenu hostile et très
médiatisée n'est aujourd'hui possible
suite au rachat par véolia des 30% de
capital que possédait angie dans suez 1
octobre dernier orange y on l'a dit a
pour principal actionnaire l'état
l'état semble donc pour le moins ne pas
s'être opposé au projet de veolia
il semblait donc être favorable à la
création de ce géant mondial des
services de l'environnement dans des
conditions de concurrence que vous nous
avez précisé
sur le fond cette opération interroge et
je ne crois pas pour ma part aux
arguments développés quant à la taille
car nous sommes dans un domaine
économique qui ne présente pas de
rendement croissante
je crois même que l'ambition
internationale ne s'exerce au détriment
des marchés français et que celui-là
surenchérissent le prix de l'eau et des
déchets pour nos collectivités et nos
concitoyens monsieur le ministre
pourquoi accepte t on encore les opéras
hostile dans notre pays
elles sont pratiquement absentes aux usa
et dans les pays du nord de l'europe
hormis la fusion bnp paribas en france
elles ont presque toujours échoué il
suffirait de prendre en compte non
l'intérêt des seuls actionnaires mais
celui de l'entreprise
l'intérêt social de l'entreprise pour
dépasser ces situations ne pensez vous
pas monsieur le ministre à l'encadrement
renforcé des hauts pays hostile pour
réconcilier les français l'entreprise
mais aussi pour reconquérir notre
souveraineté nationale serait nécessaire
peut-on imaginer une juridiction
indépendante qui veille au respect de
l'intérêt social de l'entreprise
je vous remercie merci cher collègue
monsieur le ministre
moi je partage votre raisonnement
monsieur le sénateur sur la concurrence
et je n'ai cessé de le dire depuis le
début de notre débat la taille n'est pas
un gage succès dans tous les secteurs
économiques et penser de manière un peu
courte qu'il suffit de rassembler à
chaque fois les acteurs pour qu'ils
soient toujours plus gros toujours plus
important pour que ça garantissent le
succès de cette entreprise
ça peut être vrai dans certains secteurs
ce n'est pas forcément dans d'autres et
dans le domaine de la gestion de l'eau
la gestion des déchets comme vous venez
de l'indiquer je ne suis pas certain que
ce soit la voie la plus pertinente donc
en revanche maintenir une concurrence
notamment pour que les collectivités
locales puissent avoir des choix me
semble ne voit plus pertinente
est ce que c'est possible entre veolia
et suez oui est ce qu'un partage
d'activités raisonnable est satisfaisant
pour les deux entreprises est possible
oui est-ce qu'il suffit de bonne volonté
pour y arriver
oui à que les acteurs fassent preuve de
cette bonne volonté et je suis convaincu
que ils pourront y aille
il ya d'autres secteurs en revanche ont
en raison des économies d'échelle des
secteurs qui sont très capitalistique je
pense à l'industrie automobile ou la
déconsolidation sont nécessaires parce
que vu le prix des plateformes la
nécessité d'investir dans le véhicule
électrique de renouveler complètement
les chaînes de production d'avoir de la
recherche son véhicule autonome il est
indispensable de consolider secteur et
de ce point de vue là le rapprochement
entre psa et fc as et la création de cet
élan tice est une très bonne nouvelle
pour la france et pour l'italie une très
bonne nouvelle pour l'europe car nous
créons un champion mondial tu va
permettre d'amortir des coûts très
élevés avec une entreprise qui sera plus
solide
industriellement technologiquement et
financièrement
enfin sur le caractère hostile de
l'opération je le redis une nouvelle
fois je ne pense pas que ce soit l'image
que nous voulons donner de notre
économie de nos industriels de nos
entreprises et je pense nous sortirions
tous grandi à voir une opération qui se
fasse de manière amicale
plutôt que de manière hostile monsieur
total
merci monsieur minutes pour ces éléments
mais n'est pas totalement répondu à ma
question sur le fait d'outiller
davantage l'état pour ne pas compter
seulement sur la bonne intention des
acteurs la loi pacte que vous avez voulu
et que j'ai suivi et soutenu avant de
devenir parlementaire avec un regard
passionné sur les espoirs qu'elle
pouvait faire naître sur l'évolution de
notre rapport à l'entreprise en
particulier notamment à partir des
travaux de la commission présidée par
jean dominique senard alors encore
auvergnats et nicole notât la loi pacte
ne devrait-elle pas éviter justement ce
type de situation on le voit le chemin
vers la société de mission à la raison
d'être de l'entreprise par delà sa
profitabilité est encore long
l'actualité nous le monde dans d'autres
dossiers
je pense qu'on pourrait aller plus loin
dans ce sens sur merci merci sarko avec
la parole à notre collègue edouard
courtial
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre le rachat de suez
par veolia est souvent présentée à
raison d'ailleurs comme la bataille de
l'eau en effet cette opération est
susceptible d'avoir des conséquences
importantes et très direct pour nos
concitoyens mais aussi pour les élus
locaux qui gèrent la ressource et
suscite à ce titre mes préoccupations
bien légitimes auxquelles l'état doit
répondre aux besoins en prenant toutes
ses responsabilités
elle s'exprime notamment à l'occasion de
la cession éventuelle par véolia de la
branche eau de suez au fonds
d'investissement méridiam afin de
garantir la poursuite d'une véritable
concurrence
en effet il est impossible d'avoir
demain qu'un seul géant de l'eau en
france sachant que les deux entreprises
veolia et suez sont déjà pratiquement en
situation de duopole sur ce secteur le
troisième acteur le groupe sort étant
bien plus petit or au terme de ses
différentes éditions conduite
conjointement par la commission des
affaires économiques et celle du
développement durable qui suivent ce
dossier avec constance et précision suez
doutent de la capacité de ce fonds à
maintenir et à développer les savoirs
faire de suez et donc à exercer une
pression concurrentielle pourtant
promise car soyons clairs meridiam n'est
pas spécialisée dans le secteur de l'eau
le fonds d'investissement réoriente
certes ces actifs vers des activités
relatives au développement durable mais
quelle est la capacité d'un fonds qui
gère eu milliards d'actifs
absorbé suez au dont le chiffre
d'affaires est de plus de 2 milliards
d'euros
écrasez les dettes écrasés par les
dettes sera-t-il contraint de
désinvestir une fille née presque la
totalité ce qui leur à acheter méchaal
ministère garantie avez vous obtenu de
la part de ce fonds d'investissement car
par cette opération nous savons ce que
nous perdons deux champions
internationaux français sans connaître
précisément ce que nous gagnons à l'état
actionnaire minoritaire d' influence
bien une fille de sont assurés afin
d'éviter toute mauvaise surprise comme
cela a pu être le cas par le passé à
l'occasion de sessions malheureuse je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre mais
monsieur de sénateurs cher edouard
courtial d'abord merci pour la qualité
des travaux qui ont été conduits par la
commission des affaires économiques sur
le sujet nous avons suivi évidemment de
près mais j'en remercie la présidente
sophie primas nous ne rentrons pas
aujourd'hui dans le détail des
négociations et des propositions qui
sont faites par des fonds par des
acteurs financiers
tant que les choses ne sont pas
stabilisés je pense qu'ils ne seraient
pas responsables de prendre position
pour les uns pour les autres
la seule chose que je souhaite c'est
fixer le cadre global et je pense que ce
débat aide grandement à fixer le cadre
global
une opération qui doit être amical n'est
pas une opération hostile
une opération qui doit préserver la
concurrence entre les acteurs et vous
l'avez rappelé
c'est absolument essentiel pour les
collectivités locales
une opération qui ne porte pas atteinte
à l'emploi sur le territoire parce qu'on
sait que dès qu'il ya rapprochement a
fortiori fusion il y à un risque pour
l'emploi sur les territoires est une
option qui gardent ont été rappelés par
un certain nombre d'entre vous les
qualités technologiques et industrielles
de ces deux grands groupes industriels
sur cette base là nous examinerons les
différentes propositions je le redis ces
acteurs privés c'est à eux de trouver
l'accord mais cet accord aujourd'hui je
considère qu'il reste possible
je vous conseille un nom
donc dernière question de cette série
notre collègue jean baptiste blanc en
deux minutes
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues leur pardon pour une
questions répétitives mais j'ai
l'impression que nous voulons tous
tellement la même chose c'est une sortie
de crise que je me permettrai de répéter
certaines positions
alors en fait seul ministre vous êtes
bien conscient que depuis six mois que
c'est plus de six mois que cette affaire
a commencé et que les deux fleurons
français c# par voie de presse et devant
les tribunaux cette guerre intestine ne
peut plus durer tant elle fragile et
fragilise
outre le caractère assez indécent du
spectacle qui nous offrent effectivement
tant qu'élu de la nation nous ne pouvons
pas détourner le regard et laisser cette
situation en l'état on a tous le devoir
de peser pour qu'ils se parlent qu'ils
échangent qu'on trouve une solution
l'enjeu on a tous dit est colossal il ya
d'abord l'enjeu de l'eau le 22 mars
dernier on a fêté la journée mondiale de
l'eau il rappelait que c'était denrées
extrêmement précieuse l'enjeu de
l'emploi on l'a tous dit je vais pas m'y
attarder si ce n'est qu' on peut quand
même rappeler que l'effet de taille ne
s'impose pas comme comme une évidence on
l'a tous compris
évidemment il faut aussi rester très
vigilants pour cette situation de quasi
monopole qui sur ce secteur qui
pourraient découler de cette situation
le fait qu'il n'y ait pas de concurrence
est significative éventuellement et que
donc nos concitoyens nos collectivités
locales indiennes et des victimes
on n'a vraiment pas été convaincu
monsieur milices para meridiam alors ne
pas parler meridiam cet après-midi et
mai en commission des affaires
économiques
quand on les interroge sur les
délégations de service public le devenir
des contrats publics des marchés publics
pour nos collectivités locales ils ne
nous ont pas rassurés du tout or l'eau
et les déchets sont effectivement
particulièrement stratégique
il y a une connaissance historique des
réseaux de la part des opérateurs dont
on ne peut pas se passer de toute
évidence à monsieur le ministre
véritablement il faut les aider à
trouver cet accord hautement stratégique
pour notre pays
il faut un état médiateur de la
république même si l'état n'est pas
strictement partie on a bien compris
rien ne l'en empêche juste encore un
effort monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre
nous allons faire cet effort ce sénateur
cher jean baptiste blanc ce que je pense
qu'il est utile que même si nous
rencontrons pour dire certaines
réticences à dire davantage de la part
d'acteurs qui sont parfois bloquées sur
leurs positions de départ etc un peu de
mal à trouver la voie du dialogue de
l'entente
peut-être qu'ils n'ont pas la même
pratique que celle que nous avons tous
ici du dialogue et du compromis mais je
pense qu'elle est nécessaire cette voie
là pour notre industrie
pour ces deux acteurs industriels pour
les salariés qui sont derrière auquel je
pense parce que je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup d'inquiétudes chez des salariés
de suez qui se disent mais qu'est ce que
nous allons devenir qu'est ce qui va se
passer et que notre responsabilité à
tous est justement de rassurer ses
salariés de leur donner des perspectives
et de leur garantir que l'opération peut
se faire de manière amiable
je suis profité de la dernière question
du sénateur jean baptiste blanc pour
vous remercier d'avoir organisé ce débat
parce que je pense qu'il permet de
définir une position qui nous rassemble
tous sur la nécessité d'une opération
amiable et chats nécessité de préserver
la concurrence sur la question de la
gestion de l'eau et du traitement des
déchets et je ne saurais trop vous dire
à quel point les auditions que vous avez
menées que vous continuerez de mener
sont aussi extrêmement utile pour savoir
quelles sont exactement les intentions
des acteurs qu'est ce qu'il souhaite
faire
quelles sont leurs intentions de long
terme quels sont leurs projets
industriels
qu'est ce qu'ils souhaitent sur
l'empreinte d'industriels sur l'emploi
sur la concurrence tout ça est
absolument indispensable
donc je ne terminerais que par un seul
mot qui est un grand merci aux sénatrice
et aux sénateurs ce soir monsieur
monsieur blanc voulait ajouter c'est bon
donc pour conclure ce débat la parole
est à franck montaugé pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
pour cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues
au terme de ce débat proposé par le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicaine il me reviennent de
conclure en tirant les enseignements des
arguments développés comme cela a été
dit le sentiment le silence
assourdissant du gouvernement tout au
long des développements de la sphère
veolia suez ne manque pas de nous
interroger
il s'agit d'entreprises françaises
leader sur la gestion de biens communs
comme l'eau qu'elles ont contribué à
développer capable tout deux devraient
aussi avec excellence et dans les
domaines qui dessine le monde de demain
plus largement la question que pose
cette affaire et d'autres qui ont déjà
défrayé la connais la chronique
souvent quand il était trop tard pour
les salariés et les territoires alors
concernés c'est de savoir quel rôle
l'état français doit jouer auprès des
entreprises françaises qui évoluent dans
une économie de marché ouverte à la
mondialisation
qu'il s'agisse pour l'état de patrimoine
industriel dont il est pour partie le
détenteur ou d'actifs considérés comme
stratégiques sans qu'il en soit
propriétaire
quelles sont aujourd'hui hors situations
de crise comme celle que nous vivons les
un jeu qui justifie que l'état prenne
part au capital d'une entreprise et à
quel niveau ou qu'il use de son
influence à propos d' actifs
stratégiques de notre débat il ressort
que les enjeux à prendre en compte sont
relatifs à l'emploi et à ses
conséquences territoriales à l'impact
environnemental et à la soutenabilité du
secteur économique concerné à la
compétitivité des entreprises et dans un
monde où les chaînes de valeur ont été
décomposé à l'extrême rendant souvent
difficile leur localisation
surplombant ces trois enjeux la
souveraineté nationale doit être notre
boussole en permanence et ce concept de
souveraineté nationale doit être
précisée par l'exécutif débattu est
évalué par le parlement peut être
monsieur le ministre dans le cadre d'une
loi cadre ou d'orientation la sphère
veolia suez présente à l'évidence et des
enjeux sociaux économiques et
environnementaux considérables pour
notre pays
or depuis la sortie d' angie du capital
de suez qui a très vite suivi la
non-reconduction de madame kocher et
l'enclenchement de l'opéra au style de
veolia
c'est silence radio ou presque de la
part du gouvernement monsieur le
monsieur le ministre quelle est la
position du gouvernement à propos de ces
deux grandes entreprises de leurs actifs
que nous considérons comme stratégiques
comme compte tenu de leur impact au plan
national et international
vous avez répondu le gouvernement
considère utiles que l'entrée au capital
de suez de fonds de pension américains
avides de rendement élevé et rapide est
un gage de consolidation du capital et
de stabilité à long terme pour les dévs
le développement futur
quels sont les objectifs et les
déterminants de la politique
actionnariale et d'influencé de l'état
français pour les entreprises françaises
à fort enjeu quel sens mettez vous dans
le concept d'état stratégies auxquelles
monsieur le ministre vous vous référez
souvent vous ne pouvez pas invoquer le
principe de la concurrence ou de la
liberté des acteurs
quand il y va de l'intérêt général des
territoires par exemple sans parler mais
c'est essentiel on le sait plus encore
en 2021 qu'en 2019 de la souveraineté
nationale en matière industrielle qu'il
s'agisse de santé de climat d'énergie de
défense et d'alimentation et je
rajouterais de culture tant la question
démocratique en dépend de plus en plus
par l'entremise du numérique
pour chacun de ces domaines dans le
cadre de politiques publiques de long
terme clairement explicitées et débattus
évalué in it in here et le parlement a
un rôle éminent à jouer dans un monde en
évolution rapide et profonde
au delà des moments de crise médiatisé à
propos de telle ou telle entreprise en
difficulté ou du vote du compte
d'affectation spéciale pour relatifs aux
participations financières de l'état
dont nous ne cessons de dire de loi de
finances à loi de finances qu'il est
très réducteur et peu claire nous devons
nous parlementaires engagés avec les
gouvernements un dialogue régulier basée
sur l'intérêt général national donc le
temps long et à l'aune des enjeu
d'emploi de compétitivité et de
soutenabilité que j'évoquais il ya
quelques instants
nous en sommes loin le gouvernement les
gouvernements doivent prendre leurs
responsabilités et cesser de s'abriter
derrière le fait accompli ou le non dit
qui laisse place à toutes sortes
d'interprétations
il faut se le dire il n'y aura pas de
développement soutenable et donc demain
de planète terre vivable pour nos
enfants s'ils ne s'instaure pas un autre
rapport au temps à la durée cela donne
une responsabilité majeure aux états
censés être les garants du temps long le
gouvernement ne peut se comporter en
banquier d'affaires seulement si dans
l'opinion et chez les élus les choix du
gouvernement semble reposer sur des
arrière-pensées non assumée c'est
l'intérêt national qui a toujours une
dimension locale qui est amoindrie et ça
dans une démocratie républicaine comme
la nôtre c'est inacceptable il est grand
temps que le gouvernement français dans
la consistance à son concept d'état
stratégie qu'ils discutent et explicite
sa politique publique actionnariale et
d'influencé économique une planification
stratégique adapté aux temps nouveaux
devrait en résulter
je ne crois pas me tromper en disant que
la chambre haute est prête à y apporter
sa contribution
elles viennent de le démontrer ce débat
de contrôler la a donc amplement
démontré et je remercie tous les groupes
qui se sont exprimés
[Musique]